[Musique]
oh
il ya quelques semaines il m'est arrivé
un truc qui m'a pas mal fait réfléchir
c'était l'anniversaire d'une copine dans
un bar et je me suis retrouvé à côté
d'un mec que je connaissais pas on
commence à discuter et assez rapidement
le mec me demande ce que je fais dans la
vie et je lui réponds je suis chef
d'entreprise et j'ai une marque de
vêtements et le mec me demande à quoi
comme vêtements et je lui réponds en
fait on fait des vêtements qui durent
longtemps pour que les gens n'aient pas
besoin de racheter tous les quatre
matins et là le mec s'arrête
il me regarde dans les yeux et me dit ça
marchera jamais bah si les gens n'ont
pas besoin de racheter tes vêtements à
un moment où l'entreprise elle pourra
plus grossir et je suis désolé mais dans
ces conditions je vois pas comment une
boîte comme la tienne elle peut
connaître la réussite
pourquoi il pense ça si je suis son
raisonnement
la réussite de mon entreprise ça serait
de vendre toujours plus de vêtements
quitte à vendre de la mauvaise qualité
en gros pour lui grossir c'est réussir
quel qu'en soit le prix si par réussir
on entend croissance infinie du chiffre
d'affaires amélioration perpétuelle des
profits alors il a raison effectivement
une entreprise est pas vraiment sur la
route du succès contrairement à d'autres
dans le domaine du textile qui chaque
année vendent un peu plus de vêtements
c'est le cas de nike chez m zara prime
marque seulement on leur croissance elle
a une conséquence chaque année on
produit plus de vêtements entre 2000 et
2014 la production de mondial de
vêtements a été multiplié par deux
pourquoi pas si ça permet aux gens de
pas tous habillés en jean pull gris et
chaussures blanches
le problème c'est que pour produire
toujours plus de vêtements on rejette
dans l'atmosphère des millions de gaz à
effet de serre des millions de tonnes de
co2 est-ce que vous avez une idée de ce
que ça représente l'industrie textile
sur le volume total de gaz à effet de
serre papa
8,1 pour cent c'est autant que
l'ensemble du transport routier de la
planète dans ces conditions est ce qu'on
peut continuer à vouloir produire
toujours plus tout en luttant contre le
dérèglement climatique
a priori ce n'est pas incompatible
il ya des entreprises qui plantent des
arbres pour compenser le carbone
qu'elles émettent dans l'atmosphère il
ya des mecs qui sont en train de bosser
sur des puits de carbone artificiels c
des espèces d'énormes machines qui
viennent aspiré le co2 de l'atmosphère
et j'ai même entendu parler d'un mec qui
aurait trouvé la solution à la pollution
plastique des océans donc des solutions
technologiques qui permettent de
concilier la croissance des entreprises
et la protection de l'environnement
franchement vous dirai qu'un appelant
non mais du coup pourquoi est ce que le
climat et continue de se réchauffer
pourquoi est ce que chaque minute qui
passe il ya un peu plus de plastique qui
est déversée dans les océans pourquoi la
biodiversité continué à s'effondrer à un
rythme inquiétant
est ce que ces solutions sont
suffisantes pour répondre à cette
question j'ai lu pas mal de livres sur
le sujet et des rapports d'experts et le
document qui à mon sens résume le mieux
la situation actuelle c'est une lettre
que des chercheurs ont écrit suite aux
marches pour le climat de mars 2019 et
je vais vous en lire un extrait en
l'état actuel de nos connaissance il
n'existe pas de solutions technologiques
qui permettent à toute la planète
d'avoir notre niveau de confort actuel
sans mettre en péril le climat et le
vivant et les gens qui vous disent le
contraire se trompent par ignorance on
fait des erreurs de calcul ou montre par
intérêt
ok ces solutions technologiques elle
n'existe pas encore elle n'existe pas
encore mais franchement il ya tellement
de monde qui bossent sur le sujet que il
ya quand même une chance qu'on les
trouve n'en ait de quoi cette chance 1%
soyons optimistes 10 % 10 % de chances
qu'on trouve une solution technologique
au dérèglement climatique est ce qu'on
prend le risque
imaginez vous arrivez avec toute votre
famille devant un avion tout
bringuebalant et là le pilote vous dis
qui a 10 % de chances qu'il arrive
entier à destination est-ce que vous
monter dedans même s'il y avait 50 %
même si avec 80% de chances que le
trajet se passe bien
ni vous ni moi ni personne ne montons
avec notre famille dans cet avion ce
vous aviez dupont de ligonnès mais on en
parle à une autre fois on ne peut pas
compter sur la technologie pour nous
sauver face à l'urgence climatique
actuel la seule chose qu'on puisse faire
c'est de produire et consommer moins
quoi qu'on vous raconte
quelles que soient les merveilles high
tech qu'on agite devant vos yeux il a
une équation qu'on ne pourra jamais
changer produire c'est polluer il vaudra
toujours mieux produire un tee shirt que
deux même si les deux sont en coton bio
même si on plante des arbres derrière
du coup il faut vraiment changer notre
état d'esprit on ne peut plus considérer
que la croissance des entreprises c'est
une réussite
c'est cet état d'esprit qui nous a mis
dans la situation de crise climatique
actuel la dernière fois que j'ai dit ça
ya un mec qui s'est levé qui m'a
interpellé je vous jure il a fait un
truc du genre
vous êtes bien mignonne avec votre
discours décroissance sauvons la planète
écologie mais vous êtes bien contente
d'en vendre des pulls moi j'ai
l'impression que votre discours c'est
surtout une manière de vous différencier
des autres marques pour au final vendre
plus avouez que c'est exactement ce que
vous êtes en train de vous dire
et franchement je comprends je ne vous
en veux pas quoi on l'a vu mille fois
non toutes ces marques qui prétendent
soutenir les luttes contre le racisme
l'homophobie le sexisme la grossophobie
juste pour faire parler d'elle et
derrière vendre plus et en ce moment
c'est exactement ce qui est en train de
se passer avec l'écologie dans la
plupart des entreprises
l'environnement s'est vu comme une
manière de augmenter les ventes et le
paradoxe c'est que plus les ventes
augmentent plus la crise climatique
s'aggrave
du coup je comprends que vous ayez envie
de prendre avec des pincettes
un discours de protection de
l'environnement qui sortent de la bouche
d'une chef d'entreprise en fait on
arrive même à se demander si ça existe
une entreprise qui ne cherche pas la
croissance à tout prix
pourquoi est ce que mon entreprise elle
serait différente pour une raison simple
dans mon entreprise on a compris que la
taille optimale n'est pas la taille
maximale grossir plus ne nous rendra ni
plus efficace ni plus performants ni
plus heureux nous sommes actuellement
cinq à travailler pour ma marque de
vêtements et c'est suffisant pour
fabriquer et distribuer des vêtements de
qualité tout en étant rentable est
heureux d'aller au boulot chaque matin à
quoi bon être cent fois plus nombreux à
quoi bon être cent fois plus gros
la réussite des entreprises n'est pas à
leur croissance c'est à cause des
entreprises c'est à cause de leur
obsession pour la croissance qu'on est
dans l'état d'urgence climatique actuel
pourtant je crois qu'on a encore besoin
des entreprises
je crois qu'on a besoin d'elle pour nous
chauffer nous nourrir nous habiller mais
je crois aussi qu'on a besoin d'elle
pour rendre nos téléphones plus
réparable pas pour rajouter une
troisième caméra pour rendre nos
voitures plus légères afin qu'elles
consomment moins d'énergie
pas pour les rendre encore plus
puissante pour relocaliser notre
fabrication de vêtements pas pour faire
des vestes connecter à quoi ça sert une
veste connectés je crois qu'on a besoin
d'un écosystème de petites et moyennes
entreprises utile et pas d'un monde
dominé par quatre grosses boîtes qui
n'ont qu'une seule idée en tête doubler
la concurrence parce qu'une forêt qui
résistent une belle forêt c'est pas
trois gros arbres avec des troncs de 4
km de diamètre qui aurait absorbé tous
les autres une forêt résiliente une
forêt riche écologiquement c'est des
milliers d'arbres de taille et d'espèces
différentes
et en fait si vous regardez un peu
autour de vous
des entreprises qui sont utiles et qui
cherche pas la croissance à tout prix en
appelant et mon fournisseur d'énergie
enercoop il ya le boulanger en bas de
chez moi il ya bien ces petits
l'entreprise qui fabrique ma brosse à
dents il ya la maraîchère chaque ils
achètent mes légumes
il ya même un mec qui a un restaurant de
poisson sur le bord de la loire il y en
a des millions on fait des petites et
moyennes entreprises qui vont très bien
sans chercher à conquérir le monde
pourtant c'est pas du tout à ce genre
d'entreprise là que le mec du bar celui
dont je vous parlais au début pense
quand il me parle d'une boîte qui
réussit comment ça se fait il y en a
autant autour de lui les petites
entreprises qui m'ont très bien pourtant
pourquoi lui quand il pense à une
entreprise qui réussit qui pensent à une
grosse boîte à une boîte qui croient en
permanence mais on se met deux minutes
dans sa tête vous êtes mecque où vous
êtes quelqu'un qui cherche à qui a très
envie de monter une boîte où vous êtes
déjà à la tête d'une entreprise et vous
ouvrez le journal vous verrez qu'on y
célèbre les levées de fonds record les
entrées en bourse fracassante
vous lirez que le graal pour une
entreprise c'est de devenir une licorne
c'est à dire de valoir un milliard
d'euros vous verrez qu'on récompense des
dirigeants des grandes entreprises en
les payant en moyenne 83 fois le salaire
d'une aide soignante
regardez à présent du côté des
récompenses officielles ou vrai qu'on
décerne la légion d'honneur au patron
des entreprises françaises qui ont
inondé le monde de leurs produits peu
importe que ça a coûté à notre société
ça a été le cas récemment avec le patron
de sanofi
l'entreprise pharmaceutique responsable
du scandale de la dea paquin ça dépote
l'aider paquin c'est un médicament qui a
causé des troubles mentaux et physiques
j'ai des dizaines de milliers d'enfants
rendez vous à présent dans une librairie
et demandé à consulter les biographies
d'entrepreneurs qui se vendent le mieux
vous verrez des ouvrages à la gloire de
ceux qui ont monté des empires comme
nike ou apple je vous lirai que ces
personnes sont présentés comme des
modèles mais qu'on ne traite pas du tout
sur ce qu on a sacrifié pour leur succès
vous saviez que dans les années 90 on a
découvert ces des enfants qui fabrique
et les baskets nike et vous saviez que
les conditions de travail dans les
usines qui fabriquent nos iphone sont si
déplorable qu'on les appelle les usines
à suicide dans l'imaginaire collectif
grosse boîte et glorifié et ceux qui les
ont monté ce qui les dirigent sont
starifié érigé comme modèle au reste de
la société
leurs parcours leurs méthodes leurs
modèles sont étudiants en école de
commerce
or l'histoire nous a montré que les
volonté de conquête mondiale sont
mortifères c'est cette ambition celle de
grossir plus jour plus celle d'être plus
gros que le voisin qui nous a poussés à
piller à coloniser exterminer et à
réduire en esclavage
oui les entreprises ont une énorme part
de responsabilité dans l'accroissement
des inégalités et dans la catastrophe
climatique on est en train de vivre
elles sont aussi les mieux que les mieux
placés pour freiner ce désastre et si
elle s'y met pas je me demande si on a
vraiment une chance si on veut que la
réussite des entreprises ne se passe
plus ni aux dépens des humains ni aux
dépens de la planète
il faut changer notre définition de la
réussite et ça commence par changer ses
représentations
imaginez que vous auriez le journal et
vous tombiez sur une double page qui
parle de pierre schmidt le patron d'une
entreprise textile basée en alsace qui
est connu pour deux choses avoir résisté
aux sirènes de la délocalisation et
avoir mis en place un système de
traitement des eaux usées exemplaires
imaginez quand vous rendant dans votre
librairie vous découvrirez que le
best-seller du moment c'est le livre de
thomas uriel l'homme qui a réussi à
relocaliser une filière de fabrication
de jeans en france imaginez qu en école
de commerce on se met à étudier le
business model de la boulangerie en bas
de chez moi qui depuis trente ans ont
fait les mêmes produits vent les mêmes
quantités et sans porte plutôt bien
imaginez ce que ça serait si la
représentation de la réussite n'était
plus celle de la croissance j'ai une
bonne nouvelle
des choses que je viens de vous décrire
elles sont déjà en train d'arriver
il était temps il est temps que la
réussite ne soit plus celle de l'argent
mais de l'impact positif
il est temps que les entreprises
oeuvrent au bien collectif et non plus à
l'enrichissement de quelques uns oui
elles seront moins grosses mais c'est
leur taille ou notre survie donc à
choisir
oui
la définition de la définition de la
réussite est en train de changer et
j'espère que ça s'arrêtera pas là
j'espère que l'année prochaine quand mon
ami être à nouveau son anniversaire et
je me retrouvais dans un bar assise à
côté d'un mec que je connais pas et
qu'on commencera à discuter et qui
finira par me demander ce que je fais
dans la vie et je répondrai je suis chef
d'entreprise j'ai créé une marque de
vêtements qui durent longtemps pour que
les gens n'aient pas besoin de racheter
tous les quatre matins j'espère que le
mec s'arrêtera me regardera dans les
yeux et me dire ah bah ça marchera
jamais
tout le monde c'est déjà ça merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
julia port